Good morning, John.
In 2008, I made a video called The Anagramming Guide to the Presidential Elections,
in which I anagrammed the names of presidential candidates and came up with funny things, and then
like a week later, The Daily Show anagrammed the names of presidential candidates
and I was like, [unintelligible]
And mostly I was just excited that The Daily Show
thought I was worth stealing from
but then on you being you because you're
a writer and you have lots of writer
friends were able to determine that, in
fact, The Daily Show had written that
segment before I wrote mine. People have
ideas concurrently, all the time. And a
certain number of people who had those
ideas will actually execute those ideas,
leading to a debate over who thought of
it first. Really unproductive. And
uninteresting. And then I get tweets or
tumblr messages from people who are like
Target store your giraffe love thing.
No they didn't. A designer had the same
idea that I did, that giraffes could make
hearts with their necks, and I am more
power to 'em, I'm all for artists making
a living.  Moving into the past even
further here, in 2007, John, your friend
Katie Else put DFTBA on the end of her
to-do list. We stole that from her
and popularized it through this video blog
and now DFTBA is a thing that I'm proud
of and that I identify with and lots of
people make DFTBA stuff. Some of those
people are just crafty, createy
people on Etsy, and some of them are big,
global corporations. Are those people
stealing from us? Are they stealing from
Katie? Are they stealing from no one?
Personally, I like it when it's stuff
that I like, like this sewn greeting card
by socutebykrista on Etsy, and then I
don't like it when it's stuff that I
don't really like like this shirt from
Delia's that, also in addition to saying
don't forget to be awesome, says keep
calm and party on! Like one meme wasn't enough!
But there's a difference between having
a sense of ownership over something like
I do over DFTBA, and actually owning it. I
personally don't want to cave in to that
desire for control. I have been able to
create a really cool project based on
the work of another creator, that creator
being Jane Austen, who I do not put
myself on the same level with, to be
clear. And Walt Disney interestingly did
the same thing with Alice in Wonderland,
and The Little Mermaid, and Cinderella.
Those were all stories before Disney
came along and made them into movies. But now,
Disney has turned, and is the primary force
behind extending the copyright length
forever.
The good news is the internet is making all
of this obsolete. Fewer and fewer
corporations are enforcing copyright in
the way that they used to,
there's just too much derivative work
going on.
I remember when wizard-rock was first
happening, and like the publishing companies
behind Harry Potter were like "no, you
can't make derivative works based on
Harry Potter, you can't make Harry Potter
songs". And yeah, you can. Why would you
stop people from being enthusiastic
about your creations? Hagh!
Now when somebody posts a lip-sync
video of One Direction, [lip synching to One Direction] the video doesn't get taken down.
YouTube's algorithms identify it as a
One Direction song,
advertisement pop up on it, and Sony
Music international gets the money from
those advertisements. This is not law! In
fact, it's not really legal. But the
lip-sync person gets to keep having
their video online, and One Direction
gets to make money, and everybody's happy,
so the law doesn't really come into it.
It's kind of just corporations deciding what's
ok and what isn't. Which is worrisome.
Almost all creations before, you know,
the 1700s, were collaborative creations.
Like, a song could be written by dozens of
different people over hundreds of years.
And the internet is again, full of things
like that.
Creations that about making people happy
or making them laugh or making them
think or getting a reaction. Not
about increasing personal wealth or
controling creative vision. Ideas being
free might not be good for the
pocketbooks of individuals scattered
around the world, but it is better for
society and culture as a whole. And that's
that's what makes life beautiful!
Oh-oh! John, I'll see on Monday. I actually will be
seeing John on Monday, that wasn't a
screw-up, and I may be seeing you as well
because we're having two pre-Carnegie
rehearsal shows in New York. Tickets are
ten dollars
all proceeds go to charity link, in the
description. Bye.